and now to politics we are just a day
away from the presidential election
early in-person voting ended here in
nevada on friday but you can still drop
off your mail-in ballot ahead of
tomorrow
bianca holman live this morning with
some last minute reminders for voters
bianca good morning
hey good morning john so like you said
polling locations they'll be open in
just 24 hours
coming up here on tuesday but you can
still drop off your mail-in ballot today
here at the elections department
in north las vegas if you don't want to
drop it in the mail now
thousands cast their ballots in early
voting which ended on friday
and also lots of people put in their
mail-in ballot
now all active and registered voters
were sent their ballot in late september
early october
state records show more than a million
ballots have been cast so far
the elections office still expect a big
turnout tomorrow
monday we only have one facility
available it's only here at our office
965 trade drive
we'll be completely focused on making
sure that we're ready for election day
on election day the full vote center
allocation will be providing that and
yes we do expect
a number of voters to take advantage of
that a reminder to all voters
do not wait in line with those who are
wanting to vote in person
come to the front there'll be a staffer
there with a ballot box to make sure
it's sealed and that you've signed it
again pretty easy process now there have
been some reports around the country and
you may have been reading about this
about changing your vote
some states allow that but here in
nevada we do not allow you to change
your vote
and of course a reminder again if you
have your mail inbound that you want to
drop off you have until tomorrow at 7 pm
to drop that off
in person if you don't want to drop it
off in the mail and coming up in the
next half hour i'm going to share
how you can check the status of your
ballot online or by phone
reporting live here in north las vegas
at the elections department bianca
holman 8 news now
all right bianca thank you very much our
election night coverage here on 8 news
now starts tomorrow afternoon at 4.
together with cbs news we'll be on all
night bringing you up to the minute
numbers as soon as they come in
you can get everything you need from the
local level all the way to the race for
the white house
on air and online eight newsnow dot com